any player that's up to negotiation they
have an obligation um
to support and represent the rest of the
nfl and where this game is going and i
think
mr jones just said it this contract
shows where this game is going
financially right not just in the
quarterback position but in
in all the positions uh so obviously
years later when i'm back at it'll be in
different circumstances but
i think i had a responsibility and
obligation uh to the other quarterbacks
and to the other men and even the guys
on my team
to get this done prescott from wednesday
announcing the new contract
finally between dak and the dallas
cowboys
mike what are you going to do with
yourself what are you going to do
how what are you going to talk about for
the next eight years
i i you made a cottage industry of dak
prescott
peter we're just we're three years away
from the cowboys being on the clock to
have to renegotiate or see him walk away
as an unrestricted free agent this is
not over this is not over
round one is over round two is looming i
got two things to say though based on
that clip he made
reference at one point to a comment from
jerry jones
about and jerry bought into this
narrative this goofy narrative that
popped up that they did this deal
because jerry has some sort of
inside information that no one has about
who would have guessed the nfl making a
bunch of money under the next wave of tv
deals like that's some justification
for losing their shirt at the poker
table with dak prescott
it's bizarre but it makes sense because
jerry can't sit up there and say
hey i lost my shirt at the poker table
with dak prescott
he's got to make it look like he wanted
to do what he meant to do it
we all know that a huge influx of cash
is coming
that's not why this deal was done peter
this deal was done because prescott
refused and waited and declined every
offer they made
they misread the room they overplayed
their hand
and they undersold dak prescott until
they had no choice
but to give him four years 160 million a
contract that in many ways is the best
contract any nfl player has ever signed
yeah it was a very interesting
negotiation mike and as you say
you know this contract you know two
years ago
could have gotten done for pick a number
32
i don't know it could have gotten done
for a far more reasonable number than
this one
and having said that if you look at the
cap number that he played for in 2020
and then you look at what he's gonna get
in the next four years
or next three years plus a renegotiation
dak press got one he won by
holding the line and by doing what he
said he was going to do
you know he never preached this he said
he basically let his agent todd france
handle this
but he basically was never going to take
you know 85 cents on the dollar because
he was
quote a dallas cowboy and that's worth
so much
well and the reality for the cowboys is
they should have swooped in the moment
the window opened on a second contract
for dak prescott
technically the window opened on
completion of the 2018
regular season that day as soon as that
game's over
you can sign them to a new contract even
before the playoff game they had a
wild card game against the seahawks that
year that they won then they lost to the
rams the following week in the
divisional round
that's when the window opens to do that
second deal
and one thing we've learned through this
dak prescott exercise
is the longer you wait the more
expensive it gets
and it will get expensive to the point
where you have no choice
but to make him the highest paid player
on value at signing in league history at
40 million dollars
you have to make him a record signing
bonus offer of 66 million record payout
in year one of 75 million record full
guarantee at signing of 95 million
because the alternative was you pay him
37.68 million this year and it becomes a
free agent next year as a practical
matter
the counterbalance to that though peter
is jared goff
because the rams surely wish they hadn't
paid jared goff after three years so
it's ultimately incumbent on the team
first to know
this is our guy and then to mobilize
and make him an offer he can't refuse
now because
later it's going to be ridiculously more
expensive than it is now and that's the
challenge
faced by the ravens with lamar jackson
the bills with josh allen
and the browns with baker mayfield
question one is this our guy
if the answer is yes break the bank now
because the the the bank is going to be
broken and the vault is going to be
emptied later
yeah and i think mike this there is a
uh there's a lesson to be learned here
okay and here's the lesson
if you wait and you make somebody
you know either the highest paid in
history or close to it
you have to understand that that in many
cases that is your fault
and in this case i'm blaming uh jerry
and stephen jones
it was their fault that it got to this
number
because they waited and the one thing
that you know about quarterback
contracts mike
is that the number never goes down and
it's not necessarily that you
pay the best guy the most money
you don't do that remember back in 2013
joe flacco
i'm gonna play it out i'm gonna bet on
myself i'm gonna do that so what happens
he becomes the nfl's first 20
million dollar player so just imagine
this mike in the span of
probably a little bit less than eight
years the
nfl quarterback king has gone
and and the salary of a quarterback in
the nfl
the top guy has gone from 20 to 40
and even more than that really because i
don't know
how really you consider patrick mahomes
contract
you know because spread out over such a
long period of time
i don't know how fair it is to compare
it to a
three or to a four-year contract for
like a mahomes
or uh you know or a watson or i'm sorry
a watson or a um you know uh
who am i thinking of deck but yeah dak
right
but when you think about these contracts
mike
the biggest thing is that they never go
in reverse
and for as smart as jerry jones is i
think he
totally misread the field uh two years
ago and then even a year ago he misread
it
look at that payout the first four years
of the current contract
that gets 160 over the first four years
of this contract
the other quarterbacks the first four
years of their current contracts the
numbers pale in comparison there's
mahomes
at 103.6 million for the first four
years of his deal
peter i i said last year that if the
cowboys had taken the mahomes contract
and just crossed out chiefs and put in
cowboys and crossed out my homes and put
in prescott and handed
dak prescott last year before the july
15 deadline because mahomes did his deal
before that deadline
prescott would have said no thank you
and people lost their minds how can you
say that it's a half billion dollar
contract well
yeah if you sign for long enough of
course it's going to be a half billion
dollar contract he committed for a dozen
years
dak is going to get 160 more likely he's
going to get 126 over three
and then get another contract either way
mahomes is still going to be laboring
under this deal
relying on the generosity and the
charity of clark hunt in ripping up the
contract
not every owner is going to rip up a
contract when it becomes obsolete
you think jerry jones if he had a
quarterback
and that cost certainty baked in for the
next 11 years
and the market changed the cap goes up
other players making more you think
jerry is going to rip that thing
up and say we'll just give you more
money
because we feel like it now a hold out
could force him
like it did with emmett smith in 1993 to
act and to fix it
but you you don't want to have that
commitment and just hope that the owner
of the team
who didn't get that level of money by
giving it away is going to out of the
kindness and goodness of his heart
tear up your contract you want the
contract to automatically end
and it's always better to get back to
the trough
again and again and again and that's
what makes this deal so good for dak
peter he got all those records record
signing bonus record first year payout
record full guarantee at signing
and he's only committed for four years
and as i said he's gonna be back
after three and we're gonna be doing
this again he said he's a cowboy for
life the other day no he's a cowboy for
four more years
and then he's got the leverage to
squeeze even more out of them
under this threat that maybe he won't be
a cowboy four years from now
i think patrick mahomes basically did
what tom brady did
all those years in new england which you
know back in 2004 when he did a second
contract
uh or 2005 one of those two years when
he did a second contract
he basically told the patriots
essentially
listen i'm not going to be a pig here
but i want you to i want to make sure
that you guys spend to the cap
and use the money whatever i leave here
you know on players and spend to the cap
every year and basically the patriots
did that
and that lasted that was brady's thing
over the years
you know he never was a pig you know and
and
not to say that's the wrong word to say
but he never
got absolutely the max value for himself
in new england he never did preferring
to basically say to the team
as long as you spend the money on the
rest of the team i'm okay
and that to me when i saw the patrick
mahomes contract after the initial
whoa can you believe that after that
you basically say when you look at it
like six seven eight years down the road
you know those numbers that he's going
to be making
even though they're 48 million or
whatever it is
that could be like 12 percent of the cap
then so
you know to me mahomes did something
that was very very team friendly even
though everybody would say
are you out of your mind but he did well
and that's
where dak's point that he had some sort
of an obligation to maximize his
earnings
as a favor to other quarterbacks
elsewhere
that by getting the absolute most and
this is true
when you push it as far as you can
you number one you put the bar higher so
the next guy can jump it but you also
give
other guys a chance to fall in behind so
the more dak
gets the more these other guys can get
tom brady consistently didn't push it
and it made it harder and there was a
period peter from about 2013 to 2017
where the quarterback market stagnated
and part of that was brady was clearly
the best quarterback in that time
and he didn't push for every last
penny and it makes it harder for lesser
quarterbacks to push for more when tom
brady is making x it makes it harder for
guys on the patriots
to get paid when tom brady is taking
less and it makes it harder for other
quarterbacks but
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports